honoured murdered walk walk walk is lon
lon gene watches have 110 World's Fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and more honors for accuracy than any
other time T's lon gene the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the lawn gene wit nor watch company it's
time for the launching conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus coat mr Fraser hunt famous
American journalist magazine writer and
commentator and mr. william bradford
huie editor of the american mercury our
distinguished guest for this evening is
mr. Henry Grady United States Ambassador
recently returned from Iran the opinions
expressed are necessarily those of the
speaker's ambassador Grady our Cronus
comp stroke audience has heard several
all men in the last few weeks on the
Iranian situation tonight our audience
I'm sure can get some real inside
authoritative information from you sir
now when did you go to Iran is our
ambassador in june nineteen fifty and in
june nineteen fifty sir did you as our
ambassador or did I embassy there
understand what would like that it to
happen that used for see the
developments we realize the great
importance of a settlement on the oil
questions we felt that that was basic to
any economic measures we might take to
aid the country and stem the trend
toward communism and did you alert our
state department actually and at that
time what was your analysis of the
situation did you think that that
definite action should be taken by the
British or by ourselves the Iranian
government had before it before it
spawned a supplementary agreement to the
agreement which they had signed in 1933
with the Iranian government of which
provided for an increase in the
royalties that had been signed but not
ratified and to have the royalties
become effective it is necessary to have
it ratified so it was already over a
year from the time of signing when we
arrived what was the percent that they
had it originally paid and were trying
to get an agreement to pay at that time
about thirteen to fifteen percent the
original the original now that our
mental agreement would have about double
that to 25 to 30 what were we paying at
that time the American oil companies
paying for instance to Saudi Arabia well
shortly after that time we went on a
50-50 basis which was an increase over
what we had been paying but not a not a
large increase but a substantial
suitable increase so that they were
going to pay about it a little over half
what we agreed to pack correct for our
audience sir I'd like to review that
their British had been paying about
thirteen percent and they were offering
to pay it from twenty-five to thirty
percent
and during that same period the United
States was paying a higher rate of
royalty to the Middle Eastern countries
that's correct and is it your opinion
sir that the British were at fault and
not meeting our terms in the Middle East
it wasn't so much a question of meeting
the terms regarding royalties but it was
a matter of making a number of
non-monetary concessions raz Marat came
in as prime minister in June short a few
days before I arrived and he was very
anxious to get this supplementary
agreement ratified and I believe that if
the British company had been willing to
grant him someone non-monetary
concessions he could have gotten it
ratified by the Parliament and the whole
oil question at least for the time being
would have been settled I see then
non-monetary main questions of face and
other concessions it wouldn't change
example more employ more around ians in
the clients matter of the prices charged
for oil products within Iran the amounts
of the production of the company sold in
Iran is only five percent and we felt
they could easily have given the same
prices that they were giving elsewhere
by elsewhere i'm either the British Navy
and the British Air Force as as American
ambassador did you urge the British to
make those consider very strongly and
you will feel that had those concessions
been made that we might have avoided
some of this crisis yes there's no
assurance of course but I think it would
have made it possible to get the
supplemental agreement ratified the
whole atmosphere would have been cleared
in this nationalization movement would
not have started that only came along
six months after as Mirallas prime
minister in other words in the fall of
nineteen fifty in winter 1950 well the
liberal of Labor government in London
worked very active in enforcing the a
new settlement that would it be
have been considered fair by the iranian
druid they didn't seem to be very
anxious with regard to the
nationalization of the oil industry in
iran they finally accepted the
nationalization but for some time they
were hesitant now mr. ambassador our
audience has heard this term
nationalization used over and over now
by nationalization do you mean
confiscation is that what it amounts to
in it in the Middle East it shouldn't
mean that nationalization should carry
with it the obligation for adequate
compensation for the properties taken
have the Iranians offered to pay the
British for these properties in the yes
in the law which is passed was provision
for setting side twenty-five percent of
the proceeds of from the oil operation
for paying British claims the British
would have been concerned that the
company would not make profits under
Iranian operation and hence have had no
assurance that they would get payment
for their properties can you illustrate
for us sir just how important this
matter is to the American people now
what is the oil potential in the middle
in the middle east for instance how can
you illustrate the importance of this
for Americans Iran itself produces about
six percent of the world production of
oil products it has reserves in terms of
world reserves of about seventeen
percent the rest of the area around the
Persian Gulf has reserves of about fifty
percent of the world's no reserve
another way it's almost half of the
world's known reserve is in this area
yes and consequently it's of vital
importance for the future in any terms
you may think of an industrialization
warfare or whatever you may
the public mind ambassador Grady seems
to me that the biggest fear that we have
in this country is the intrusion of rush
into this picture now how how would
Russia get this oil out say that that we
went from one failure to another and
Russia there was a coup d'etat the
resident group would get in control of
the government how could Russia really
managed to get this this oil out in a
long ways to the Black Sea yes if a
government friendly the Russia came in
as a result of a coup an agreement could
be made for sale in the oil with the
Russian government and the oil could be
a considerable quantity could be gotten
out there is a lot of oil stored in the
tanks at the port of corn Shaw and it
could be moved by tankers and by
overland by trucks in in containers I
don't think that you could move all the
oil that was produced under normal
conditions in Iran but I think a
considerable amount at least an amount
that would be embarrassing to us six
percent of sale altogether and Russia
has about the same amount of the same
percentage as but they couldn't hope to
take off more than say twenty-five
percent but oh no they they couldn't
take out in the first place I'd out of
unless there's a British company or some
kind of a company goes in to operate and
produce and sell to the market they've
sold to in the past i don't i don't
think that the Russians could get any of
the are must ambassador
interesting old gentleman mr. Mossadegh
is now a visitor in the United States do
you know him personally sir yes
extremely well is he an able and
responsible statesman he's extremely
able he's a patriot I think he's
misguided in the way he's carrying out
the nationalization program I've told
him that a number of times and I've told
him that as a friend of Iran because I
think a failure of this program of his
may be very harmful to his country and a
failure to make some kind of an
agreement with responsible management of
some responsible management company to
operate because I doubt that the
Iranians themselves can operate this
industry he's he's honest he's one of
the one of the aimless speakers in the
country very attractive personality good
sense of humor is he the Persian
gentleman is he a prisoner of the
nationalistic wave there or this revolt
against the against the west toward
agree that may be sold not to a very
great degree because the Mossadegh is a
man of great force himself with
willpower not he's not easily influenced
by anybody is he own man here is he
capable in to making it the settlement
here in the United States well he's
taken such a strong position that it
would be difficult for him to change his
position but that's because of his of
his own from his own angle he's the man
who makes the decisions he man has made
right along and answered are you hopeful
from all your knowledge are you hopeful
of a settlement there there is a common
interest a mutual interest on the part
of both sides to get a settlement of
this question when you have a situation
of that kind as always hoping societies
/ but I am NOT signs easy cuz my two
sides the 245 totally terribly i'm sorry
mr. hunt i'm afraid that that's our time
is up thank you so much for being with
us the editorial board for this edition
of the launching krona scope was mr.
Fraser hunt and mr. william bradford
huie our distinguished guest was mr.
Henry Grady our recent ambassador to
Iran